let me bring in Diana Rossini ESPN NFL
reporter have you heard about the
potential litigation here Diana with
myself and Tom Brady's legal team I
haven't but you're welcome to come back
to you
I like your setup I've been watching it
for years and I'll take that over
Bristol wedding day of the week yeah
well once we get through with quarantine
I'd love to have you in the man cave
here but yeah I came up with a tompa bay
t-shirts thinking it's so corny and then
we were selling t-shirts then I just
heard from Tom Brady's legal team that
we have to take it down not exactly a
cease-and-desist it might be a cease but
the desist is coming here pretty soon
oh well you know that he's going to own
all of that originality I mean the
corniness by the way you're spot on
there in terms of the level of cheese I
mean it's terrible
thank you I'm not so sure about that
oh I see where you're going with it it's
original I guess but I guess not so
original because the tv12 family has has
taken ownership over that so Tom you
stay out of the park let's just start
there then we'll worry about your
branding yes so I'm thinking Tom
probably was dealing with this tompa bay
potential lawsuit and he was in his
house and he said to Giselle I got to
get out I got to get out I got to take a
walk and maybe walk to the park and then
all of a sudden the mayor said you're
not allowed to go to the park you know
you're it said Brady had been cited and
then I thought I said how do they
spelling cited because it's a big
difference there if he's being cited
with a C or cited with an S it did Tom
get in trouble and who was working out
with him by the way do we know um I'm
not sure but I'm thinking that this was
the journey he's sitting in this very
small derrick jeeter home does he know
smaller than what exists there which
terrible internet connection as we saw
with his energy with Howard Stern right
so he's like he's like Oprah - he's
living in a small place is that with
horrible bandwidth he's upset that
you're trying to make money off him and
he's like I need to get out of here
here's a place where nobody's out so
I'll take advantage of it and
here's the thing we've all been pulled
over and we've all been in trouble with
the law and we all have our own moves
like what's Tom Brady's moves you know I
go with I'm pretty transparent like he's
like hey you're on your phone I'm like I
know do you want to talk to my mom she's
still on the line like I just say what
it is like I don't lie don't try you're
speeding I know
was it really fast fastest one today
what stops right
I can't see my wife she's ugly all right
a couple of things here we got this
virtual draft coming up on Thursday
starting Thursday but I how does it look
on TV how is it going to look on TV so I
I can get my audience an understanding
of they can conceptualize this the
commissioners in his basement in Jersey
and then what do I see on the screen
when we go to each team so please don't
offend Westchester County because you
know they would be offended a bunch of
adult living in your own oh my bad my
bad
yes yes not in beautiful New Jersey we
would be honored to have him though so
ya know so he'll be even based on which
by the way I learned the hard way which
this just goes to show you I need to
travel more not every home has basements
right so we live in the tri-state area
so we're used to you know just normal to
us it's house has a basement but out
west nobody has basements so not
everyone will be in a basement but the
Commissioner will be and then you're
gonna have sort of how have you I think
your listeners I'm sure you have
participated in a zoom it's going to
look very similar to that with the
commissioner in the center to start and
then it's going to be a split screen of
the team most teams are opting to have
their general manager take the shot will
say the millers why I know that is I've
asked a couple of head coaches you know
what they'll be wearing or if they
bought a selfie light you know to look
extra handsome I guess I most say well
I'm not really planning to be on camera
that much because the jams are going to
take are going to take the TV time so to
speak so on the way it was described to
me is to be that split shot and then the
player they pick the director
running the show here is going to have
control over all the players who have an
iPhone with them and are connected live
into our system until they'll be able to
pull them up so let's just use
Cincinnati as an example since he's on
the clock
there's Joe Burrell with less than ten
people I also found that out today that
if any of these prospects have more than
10 people in that shot they will not
take them live so I'm sure there's gonna
be a lot of people having their family
members just you know squatting
underneath the camera I'm waiting for
you know the ankle tom who's gonna be
your Uncle Jimmy who's going to have
like some Nike swoosh t-shirt on that
you're not allowed to have as he walks
into the shot here they said to the
prospects or the King you know the the
draft prospects you can't wear certain
things I'm waiting for somebody to
photobomb one of these zooms here oh you
know what's gonna happen I don't want it
to be one of us one of these players I
want it to be a coder Jam I think that's
funnier like just someone's random child
blocking in or you know somebody not
shutting the door and the shot of the
bathroom lawful reflection you know when
people zoom in like look it's a naked
person
I mean I don't want that for the company
but I think it would be very
entertaining for us as fans I had a
great situation yesterday where I was
talking to a head coach a few hours
after that virtual mock draft and he
just was very irritable to begin with
but probably cuz didn't want to talk to
me but that's a different story but you
know we're just chatting about the draft
and he should hold on for one second I
said yeah you think everyone get off the
internet he's like and the thing is like
i heard the voice i immediately thought
of my own father when he could yell my
full name up the stairs because i was
you know like all right listen I'm gonna
go I'll give you a ring later it turns
out whose kids were on iPad and so that
you know the bandwidth is such an issue
and you know you think these guys have
all the money in the world but they're
just like us like I'm not buying the
mega for worry
cable package I buy the regular Lydell
just like everywhere and these coaches
all say the same thing but like I'm not
going to Bob what do I need so much
bandwidth for in my home why am i I'm
not even home if the in series
is there an emergency plan like if
something goes wrong for somebody the
team loses contact of trying to make
sure that they get the pick in on time
yeah so there are phone calls basically
everyone is on the phone as well not
just through the internet so you're
never to have that backup plan that's
sort of how it's been described to me
but my favorite organizations to talk to
right now dan or those that have
embraced it and they're excited by and
they think they have a leg up on this
especially if they're technologically
savvy and I think it's pretty obvious
based on social media who those people
are because they're the ones tweeting
out the pictures of their setup and you
know they're showing that there's sort
of their draft caves you know it's funny
I sent a one head coach about how this
has all worked for them in terms of
these meetings that they have normally
leading up to the director I couldn't
get anyone on the phone last year Wow I
got a like this for a reporter but I had
one head coach put it back she said you
know I got to tell you I'm usually
sitting in a meeting with about 25
people you know I got my Scouts I got
all my personnel people I got assistants
music now it just means my GM bout we
call my owner once in a while my head of
player personnel
and that's it and we are locked in we're
not distracted by anyone I mean you can
also translate as that as just wanted to
control but it just seems like they're
cutting out the fat and the distractions
and they're able to just he believed
this was gonna be his best rap well I
think it makes you focus and you know I
had an NFL scout who said you know when
we came up with the virtual draft
reality that was you should already know
what your draft board is like there's no
excuses here and some teams were saying
hey what about communication we can't
get with our guys our war room and all
that and the Scout said no you have your
information already if you don't then
you weren't gonna be good on draft day
in the first place but are you rooting
for a technical glitch or not Dianna
oh my god yeah so I live for
I enjoyed it so much I think it's great
that every coach and gym is just like my
family so at this point they're just the
only time I can ever relate with them so
I think it would be great to this I
think we need it - we need some laughs
right now it has been so depressing and
difficult for so many people
I can I can speak we're just living in
the North Jersey area where this
coronavirus situation it is not just
okay it is very very serious so I think
it's gonna be fun I'm excited as
something to look forward to I know you
guys are usually the draft to me it's
exciting but right now with nothing else
going on I really can't wait for
Thursday to get here Thank You Diana and
have fun thanks guys that's a Diana
Rossini